during a stand-up comedy tour that was
meant to last until the spring of 2022
entertainment legend bob saget died
unexpectedly at age 65. saget was a
beloved actor who was also a staple in
the comedy world for decades one of his
most notable roles was the single father
and every man danny tanner in the hit
sitcom full house you'll likely also
know him well from his tenure as the
original host of america's funniest home
videos the most recent stop on a
stand-up tour was at the ponte vedra
concert hall in ponte vedra beach
florida at this last performance fellow
comedian tim wilkins opened up the show
for sagat who would then go on to
perform for two hours in front of a
massive audience oh you know what i got
to go on i'm sorry i got people to
entertain excuse me
after a show saga took to social media
to express his heartfelt appreciation
for the crowd along with his passion for
being a comedian his last instagram post
was not only heartwarming but a
testimony to the strong meaningful
relationship that he shared with his
fans for the tragic context of his
passing saga's last instagram post is
likely to break your heart bob saget's
very last instagram post is the selfie
that he took on the stage at the ponte
vedra concert hall with an acoustic
guitar and stool propped up just behind
him he paired the image in which he
looks directly at the camera with a
contented smile with heartfelt text
writing okay i love tonight's show at
ponte vedra concert hall in jacksonville
really nice audience lots of positivity
happened last night in orlando last
night at the hard rock live too very
appreciative and fun audiences he also
thanked tim wilkins for opening the show
and continued his post with optimism
writing i'm back in comedy like i was
when i was 26 i guess i'm finding my new
voice and loving every moment of it
sadly the post goes on to promote
upcoming tour dates which he would have
performed with fellow comedian mike
young he also teased the possibility of
a recorded special writing going
everywhere until i get the special shot
and then probably keep going because i'm
addicted to this peace out the post has
since gained hundreds of thousands of
likes on instagram and has received a
vast amount of comments that express
condolences and appreciation for the
actor and comedian fellow comedian kevin
kneeland wrote god bless you bob it's
been a lot of years with us actor danny
burstein who appeared on sagat's bob
saget's hear for you podcast in december
2021 wrote oh bobby i'll miss you
forever bob saget's last instagram post
reminds us all that even after decades
of performing he loved what he did and
his peers and fans loved him for it
then wait there's more other colleagues
who have taken to the platform to
express their condolences and heartbreak
over his passing include kat dennings
who starred in raising dad with sagat on
instagram she posted an image of the
show's stars together and shared some
words of her own she wrote i'm
speechless bob saget was the best so
kind i was his tv daughter for one
season and he was generous protective
caring and wonderful he talked about his
kids constantly rest in peace comedian
gilbert gottfried who knew saggit well
took to instagram to post a recent
selfie the two shared and reminisced
about the pair's times together the
comic wrote still in shock i just spoke
with bob a few days ago who stayed on
the phone as usual making each other
laugh rest in peace to friend comedian
and fellow aristocrat bob saget he says
that what do you call yourself and they
go the aristocrats
actor mario lopez's instagram post is a
picture of him and saget smiling for the
camera with a concise caption that
simply reads wow rest in peace bob saget
with the outpouring of love and
expressions of shock over his death it's
clear that saggett's colleagues and
peers as well as his many many fans feel
that he's gone too soon